House of the Dragon Episode 2 has a dragon
showdown, two awkward marriage proposals,
and the reveal of Craghas Crabfeeder.
So – what’s going on, and what does it
mean?
This video has no spoilers beyond Hot D Episode
2.
It starts with a new opening sequence for
the series.
It shows a model city, like the one Viserys
makes, but with a stream of blood running
through it.
This represents the bloodline of House Targaryen
– it’s a family tree showing the last
hundred years of Targaryen kings.
It starts with this image of Valyria, the
old empire of the dragonlords.
Valyria was destroyed in the mysterious Doom,
but the Targaryens survived by coming to Dragonstone.
This next image is of Aegon’s Conquest,
when Aegon Targaryen and his sisters and their
dragons took over Westeros.
Here, the bloodline splits into two – because
Aegon had one son with his sister-wife Rhaenys,
and one son with his other sister-wife Visenya.
The Rhaenys symbol shows a dragon skull with
bolt through the eye – because Rhaenys and
her dragon were shot down with a scorpion
bolt in Dorne.
Rhaenys’ bloodline continues to her son
King Aenys.
Aegon’s other son Maegor also became king,
but he never had children, and so isn’t
included in this bloodline.
After Maegor, Aenys’ son Jaehaerys became
king, and he married his sister Alysanne.
Here, the bloodline splits into nine streams.
Because Jaehaerys and Alysanne had nine children
who survived to adulthood.
Next are Jaehaerys’ kids Baelon and Alyssa
– Baelon has a Hand symbol, because Baelon
was Hand of the King.
Baelon and Alyssa’s son was King Viserys
– you can recognise his crown symbol.
Viserys married Aemma Arryn – and she’s
got the Arryn sigil.
After Aemma is long stream of blood, which
evokes Aemma’s stillbirths and miscarriages
and.. her death.
But then we see her daughter Rhaenyra – with
the symbol of the Valyrian steel necklace
that Daemon gave her last episode.
And there’s an image of the ceremony where
Rhaenyra was named heir to the Throne.
Meanwhile, in the background, we see the bloodline
of the Velaryons shown with blue symbols.
And see the bloodline of Otto Hightower with
the Hand of the King symbol – and his daughter
Alicent with the Hightower sigil.
So this new intro is a visual summary of the
Targaryen bloodline alongside the Velaryons
and Hightowers.
Maybe the intro will change throughout the
season as the family changes – cause this
season occasionally jumps forward in time
several years.
The blood imagery reminds us that the history
of the royal family is written in the blood
of birth and the blood of battle, and in a
lot of red wine.
The bloodline is running downhill, which suggests
the Targaryens are in decline, falling from
their peak at Valyria down towards fiery disaster.
The episode starts about six months after
the previous episode.
We see that Craghas Crabfeeder has attacked
another Westerosi ship.
Crabfeeder is the leader of the Triarchy,
an alliance of eastern cities who have taken
over the Stepstones islands.
Craghas is called Crabfeeder because he nails
his enemies to the beach so they get eaten
alive by crabs.
According to a behind-the-scenes video, Crabfeeder
has greyscale.
Greyscale is a disease that slowly turns the
body into stone – we saw stone men infected
with greyscale in Game of Thrones –Jorah
Mormont catches greyscale.
Greyscale can eventually cause madness, so
it looks like this disease makes the Crabfeeder
crazy and dangerous.
He wears a mask similar to the Sons of the
Harpy mask from Game of Thrones – the idea
is that Crabfeeder created his outfit from
bits and pieces that he found in shipwrecks.
Crabfeeder’s attacks are disrupting the
trade that makes Corlys rich.
So Corlys wants to attack Crabfeeder immediately.
But King Viserys doesn’t want a big war
– so he sends diplomats to the eastern cities
of Pentos and Volantis to see if they’ll
help against the Triarchy.
And this might actually be a smart move – getting
the Free Cities to sort this out amongst themselves
so the Targaryens don’t have to go to war.
But Corlys says this makes the Targaryens
look weak.
And Rhaenyra says they should send dragonriders
as a show of force.
Everyone’s talking back to King Viserys,
and questioning him, but when Rhaenyra speaks
up, Viserys and Otto shut her down and send
her away.
Rhaenyra feels frustrated that even though
she’s the heir to the Throne, she’s not
allowed to participate in politics, she’s
still just the cupbearer, Viserys is still
treating her like a “little girl”.
The Commander of the Kingsguard, Ryam Redwyne,
has died of natural causes.
And there are always seven Kingsguard, so
now they need a new member to replace Ryam.
Otto chooses candidates from houses Caron,
Mallister, Corbray, Rowan, Crakehall and Tarly
– House Tarly is the family of Sam and Randyll
in Game of Thrones.
Each candidate is represented by a carved
model – kinda like the small council balls,
and Viserys’ dragon statue – suggesting
that everyone here is just a piece in a game..
of thrones.
Otto tells Rhaenyra to say polite courtesies
to the knights, so she plays that role, with
a fake fleeting smile.
This is what’s expected of young lady – smiles
and courtesies – but Rhaenyra has more to
offer.
Otto says they should choose the Mallister
or Crakehall knight for the Kingsguard, because
those houses are important politically.
But the Kingsguard are meant to be apolitical
and unbiased, simply the best and most honourable
knights in the realm.
But when Kingsguard are chosen for political
reasons instead, that can make the Kingsguard
weaker – by the time of Game of Thrones,
most of the Kingsguard aren’t great knights
– they’re corrupt cronies, cowards and
oathbreakers.
Rhaenyra wants her father’s guards to actually
be great fighters, so she chooses Criston
Cole, because he has real battle experience
– <and also because he’s hot.
King Viserys and Alicent have a hang out..
date.. meeting, and Viserys talks about Valyria,
the old dragonlord empire.
The Valyrian capital city was built on volcanoes
called the Fourteen Flames – and Viserys
says the volcanoes were the source of Valyrian
magic and power.
The books say that “All Valyrian sorcery
was rooted in blood or fire” – their sorcerers
used glass candles that let them see across
the world, and enter peoples’ dreams.
Viserys says the Valyrian blood mages lived
in the Anogrion – anogri apparently means
blood in Valyrian.
The books say that Valyrian blood mages did
some crazy messed up stuff.
They twisted the flesh of beasts and men to
create monstrous chimeras.
In the flesh pits of Gogossos, “beasts were
mated to slave women to bring forth twisted
half-human children”.
Some fans theorise that Valyrian blood magic
created dragons, and gave the Targaryens the
dragon blood that allows them to control dragons.
In this episode, we see a painting on a wall
of a dragon having sex with humans – the
blood of the dragon may be literal.
But Viserys doesn’t mention Valyria’s
blood magic monstrosities.
[Or that his ancestors might’ve been lizards].
Or the fact that Valyria’s volcanoes were
full of slaves being worked to death in the
burning mines.
It’s crazy how Viserys admires the glory
of Valyria when Valyria was so evil – it’s
like he’s playing with a Lego model of magic
nasty Germany.
Viserys and Alicent compare Valyria and its
fall to Westeros, then Viserys drops a statue
of a dragon – which heavily foreshadows
disaster for the Targaryen dynasty.
Viserys and Alicent have been having these
meeting/hang/dates for a while.
On one level, it’s an innocent friendship
– Alicent understands Viserys’ grief for
his dead wife Aemma, because her own mother
died, so she feels real sympathy for Viserys.
But at the same time, Alicent visits Viserys
because Otto told her to, he wants her to
hook up with the king to make the Hightowers
more powerful.
Alicent’s actor said it’s “ambiguous”
to what extent Alicent is scheming for Otto
instead of being genuine.
Ultimately, Alicent is a fourteen year old
girl who has to obey her father and her king
– and we can see how anxious that makes
her feel when she picks at her fingernails.
The relationship is further complicated by
Alicent’s friendship with Rhaenyra – cause
Viserys tells Alicent not to tell Rhaenyra
about their.. meetings, which forces Alicent
to choose between loyalty to her king and
loyalty to her best friend.
Alicent and Rhaenyra go to a sept, which a..
church of the Faith of the Seven.
Alicent is a believer of the Faith – which
makes sense, because her family the Hightowers
of Oldtown, have close ties with the Faith.
But Rhaenyra is not so religious – some
Targaryens don’t worship gods, preferring
to think of themselves as gods.
So Alicent teaches Rhaenyra to pray at the
statue of the Mother, to feel closer to their
own dead mothers.
Alicent and Rhaenyra have a deep bond.
But when they talk about Viserys remarrying,
Alicent doesn’t tell Rhaenyra about her
meetings with Viserys.
So she’s not being completely honest with
her friend.
Viserys speaks with Lord Corlys and his wife
Rhaenys, who say the Targaryen throne looks
vulnerable – Crabfeeder has the Stepstones,
Dameon’s on Dragonstone, Queen Aemma is
dead, and the heir to the throne is a girl.
Corlys uses a sailing metaphor about facing
a storm, because Corlys is a famous sailor
who has travelled the world.
Corlys proposes that King Viserys marry his
daughter Laena, to make the royal family stronger
by deepening the Targaryen-Velaryon alliance.
This alliance has been shaky ever since Rhaenys
was rejected at the Harrenhal Council.
Marrying Laena to the king would bring them
closer, and would make Corlys even more powerful.
But Viserys is not keen to marry a twelve
year old girl, and he’s still grieving his
dead wife Aemma, so Viserys appears indecisive
and uncertain – which is really not how
a king should behave.
Viserys and Rhaenyra try to talk and connect,
but it’s awkward.
The silence is highlighted by the sound of
crickets, and by the physical distance between
Viserys and Rhaenyra at table.
Rhaenyra brings up the council earlier – she
wants Viserys to listen to what she has to
say – but Viserys just talks over Rhaenyra
again.
We see that Viserys’ finger is rotting – after
it was cut on the Iron Throne last episode.
This is another bad omen hinting that power
is killing Viserys, that the Throne is rejecting
him.
The rotting hand also suggests that the Hand
of the King Otto is corrupt.
Seeing maggots eat his flesh evokes Viserys’
line last episode, about crows feasting on
his family’s corpses.
This political world is eating Viserys alive,
and two of the hungriest vultures are Otto
and Mellos.
Viserys says that Corlys proposed marriage
to Laena.
And this worries Otto, cause he wants Viserys
to marry his daughter Alicent.
Otto shares some knowing looks with Grand
Maester Mellos – it’s obvious that these
two are working together.
We saw them conniving in the shadows last
episode, and saw a maester whispering in Otto’s
ear.
It makes sense that Otto is close with the
maesters, because the maesters are based in
the Hightower city of Oldtown.
Otto even wears a chain on his neck similar
to a maester’s chain.
So together, Otto and Mellos subtly manipulate
Viserys – saying yes there are good reasons
to marry Laena Velaryon, but they also say
that it would anger Rhaenyra, and that it’s
an insult to the memory of Viserys’ dead
wife.
So without saying it directly, Otto and Mellos
pressure Viserys not to marry Laena.
Viserys and Laena have an awkward walk of
courtship in the garden.
Like Sansa’s awkward walks with Loras in
Game of Thrones.
Laena and Viserys are both very uncomfortable
with this marriage proposal.
Though age gaps in political marriages are
not uncommon in Westeros.
Like, in the books, Sansa is twelve when she
marries Tyrion.
And Daenerys was thirteen when she marries
Drogo.
Girls are considered ready to have sex once
they have their first period – here Laena
says she’s expected to have sex with Viserys
when she turns fourteen.
The books emphasise the horror that Sansa
and Daenerys experience as child brides, and
show the dangers of young pregnancies – in
this world, girls’ bodies are political
objects, used to perpetuate bloodlines, just
as mens’ bodies are on battlefields.
Laena is not interested in marriage – she’s
interested in dragons.
She asks about Vhagar, the oldest and biggest
dragon in the world, ever since the death
of Viserys’ dragon Balerion.
Vhagar was the dragon of Queen Visenya Targaryen,
who conquered Westeros alongside Aegon.
Then, Vhagar was ridden by Baelon Targaryen,
the father of Viserys and Daemon.
These days, the old she-dragon has left King’s
Landing and retired to someplace on the east
coast, as many older women do.
And it’s kind of terrifying that the Targaryens
don’t know where their most dangerous weapon
is.
It’s yet another thing King Viserys is not
in control of.
Laena says the workers at Spicetown sometimes
hear Vhagar’s song – Spicetown is a trading
port on Driftmark, so maybe the Velaryons
could find Vhagar.
Rhaenyra sees her father on a date with a
twelve-year-old.
If Viserys remarries and has a son, that son
could replace Rhaenyra as heir to the Throne.
Just like Rhaenys was replaced at the Harrenhal
Council when Viserys was made heir instead
of her.
Rhaenys says this is the order of things,
“Men would sooner put the realm to the torch”
that see a woman on the Throne.
In Game of Thrones we see how hard it is for
Daenerys and Cersei to hold power, though
to be fair it is Daenerys and Cersei who torch
the realm, not the men.
Rhaenys has mixed feelings for Rhaenyra – she
feels sympathy that Rhaenyra is facing the
same obstacles she faced, but she also feels
a little jealousy, or spite, as though she
doesn’t want Rhaenyra to succeed where Rhaenys
failed.
According to the actor, Rhaenys wants to take
Rhaenyra down a peg.
But Rhaenyra insists that she’ll become
queen, and will make a new order, a more fair
political system.
Like when Daenerys she’ll break the wheel.
Will Rhaenyra succeed where Daenerys fails?
We learn that Viserys’ brother, Prince Daemon,
has been living on Dragonstone for the last
six months – despite the fact that Viserys
ordered Daemon to go to the Vale to his estranged
wife Rhea Royce.
Daemon took his gold cloaks to Dragonstone,
even though the gold cloaks are meant to be
guarding King’s Landing.
And now, Daemon does something even more provocative.
He calls himself the rightful heir to the
Throne instead of Rhaenyra.
And he says he’s gonna marry his lover Mysaria,
even though Daemon’s already married to
Rhea Royce.
The Targaryens and Valyrians have a history
of marrying multiple wives – Aegon the Conqueror
married both his sisters Rhaenys and Visenya.
But according to the Faith of the Seven, polygamy
is a sin – King Maegor went to war with
the Faith when he married six wives, after
that disaster, the Targaryens stopped their
polygamous marriages.
If Daemon brings back that tradition he could
reignite this old conflict with the Faith.
But Daemon also steals a dragon egg.
Because traditionally, the Targaryens put
a dragon egg in the cradle of their babies
so that the dragon hatchling bonds with the
baby – and Daemon says Mysaria is pregnant
with his child.
And the specific dragon egg that Daemon stole
is the egg that was going to be Prince Baelon’s,
Viserys and Aemma’s baby that was gonna
be Viserys’ heir – Daemon’s “heir
for a day” speech was what started his fight
with Viserys in the first place.
So in one day, Daemon commits treason, blasphemy,
egg theft, and insults Viserys over his dead
baby again – forcing the king to take action.
Viserys says he’ll go and face Daemon himself,
but Otto says he can’t allow that, it’s
too dangerous.
Viserys is the king, but it often seems like
Otto is the one in charge.
Later, Viserys says “I am your king”,
and in Game of Thrones Tywin says “Any man
who must say, "I am the king" is no true king”.
Otto goes to Dragonstone and tells Daemon
to surrender.
But Daemon just asks where’s Viserys.
The reason Daemon does all this is cause he
wants attention and acknowledgement from his
brother.
Daemon faces Criston Cole, the knight who
defeated him at the tournament last episode.
Daemon calls Criston “Ser Crispin” instead,
just like in Game of Thrones when Jaime calls
Dickon “Rickon”.
Daemon has his fierce and freaky blood-red
dragon Caraxes, so Otto can’t defeat Daemon
without a lot of dudes getting barbecued.
But then Rhaenyra turns up on her dragon Syrax.
With her dragon, Rhaenyra can’t be bossed
around by Otto any more – so she takes charge,
and confronts Daemon.
By calling himself heir to the Throne, Daemon
undermines Rhaenyra’s position as heir.
Dragonstone itself is traditionally the seat
of the heir to the Throne.
Rhaenyra dares Daemon to kill her and take
her place as heir – and it looks like Daemon
thinks about it – but for all his violence
and chaos Daemon doesn’t want to kill his
family, so Daemon gives up the egg.
The dragon egg is kept in this hot container,
because dragon eggs seem to like heat.
Daemon’s lover Mysaria is angry because
despite Daemon’s announcements, Mysaria
wasn’t told that they would be married,
and Mysaria isn’t pregnant – she says
she can’t get pregnant.
Mysaria says that Daemon’s political games
might be fun for him, but they could easily
get her killed.
Men like Otto see Mysaria as a disposable
hoare.
[Ironic, given how Otto is using Alicent].
We saw in Game of Thrones how people like
Cersei and Tywin treat women they see as hoares.
Mysaria says she’s been sold as property,
and lived in terror most her life – it’s
a similar backstory to Melisandre’s in Game
of Thrones, who was also a slave in the east
who learned to survive.
we saw Melisandre with Stannis brooding on
Dragonstone, much like Mysaria and Daemon
on Dragonstone.
Like Daemon, Stannis also wanted the Throne
and the love of his older brother.
Viserys goes to Lyonel Strong and asks for
unbiased advice.
Viserys knows that Corlys and Otto are trying
to use him for their political gain.
So he asks Lyonel for his outside opinion
on who Viserys should marry.
Lyonel says he should marry Laena – cause
Corlys is an important ally, and they’ll
need his ships if there’s war in the Stepstones.
But Lyonel says that “Proud men don't like
having to look up” – while Lyonel looks
up at Viserys.
Lyonel is the Lord of Harrenhal, the biggest
castle in the realm and is leader of House
Strong, “an ancient line of noble warriors”.
Surely Lyonel is a proud man too – so what
are his ambitions?
Viserys gets angry that Rhaenyra flew off
to Dragonstone without his permission.
Viserys feels very protective of Rhaenyra
– maybe because his wife died, he’s terrified
of losing his daughter too.
But Rhaenyra points out she got results – she
got the dragon egg back without violence – and
she wants to show Viserys her trust her in
her abilities.
So Viserys acknowledges that he needs to let
Rhaenyra grow into an adult.
Rhaenyra says she understands that as king,
Viserys needs to remarry and have more kids.
So for the first time in months, Viserys and
Rhaenyra really connect emotionally – but
there’s a misunderstanding here, because
Rhaenyra thinks Viserys is talking about marrying
Laena Velaryon.
But really, Viserys is thinking of marrying
Alicent.
Alicent fixes Viserys’ broken dragon statue,
so maybe Viserys thinks Alicent can fix his
broken family – or he just wants a wife
who supports his dorky hobbies.
Or he’d just rather marry a fourteen year
old than a twelve year old.
Either way, Viserys announces he’ll marry
Alicent Hightower.
And this pisses off everybody except Otto.
Corlys is furious because by rejecting Laena,
the Targaryens have rejected his family again
just like Rhaenys was rejected at the Harrenhal
Council.
Rhaenyra is upset because it’s weird that
her dad is marrying her best friend, and also
cause Viserys and Alicent kept their relationship
secret from her.
Alicent looks anxious about marrying this
old guy and becoming queen.
And Daemon will be angry, because a child
of Viserys could push him further back in
the line of succession.
Viserys marrying Alicent is not necessarily
a bad idea – as king he’s gotta marry
someone, and the Hightowers are powerful allies,
and Alicent can produce heirs sooner than
Laena can – but Viserys’ failure to communicate
with Rhaenyra and to appease Corlys creates
huge divisions at a time when House Targaryen
is already looking vulnerable.
Daemon and Corlys get together on Driftmark,
the Velaryon island.
Corlys’ home is decorated with maps and
skulls and a be-barnacled bust – artifacts
from Corlys’ sea voyages.
Corlys and Daemon are both angry at Viserys,
so they decide to do their own thing, and
to attack the Crabfeeder – to end the threat
to Corlys’ ships, and to win glory for them
both.
Corlys says House Velaryon have always been
underdogs.
Even back in Valyria, the Targaryens had dragons,
but the Velaryons didn’t, so they had to
make their own power with their ships and
grit.
Corlys is a self-made man because his voyages
around the world made his family rich.
Corlys mentions building his seat by his own
strength – cause Corlys used his wealth
to build a new castle on Driftmark, called
High Tide.
He also mentions the Driftwood Throne, which
is the seat of the Lord of Driftmark.
According to legend, the ancient Driftwood
Throne was given to the Velaryons by “the
Merling King”.
Corlys says that he and Daemon are “second
sons” who must prove their worth.
Cause the laws of inheritance mean that firstborn
sons like Viserys inherit the lordships and
lands.
Second sons, like Daemon and Otto often inherit
nothing.
So they’ve got to find their own place in
the world.
Some second sons join the maesters, or the
Faith, or the Night’s Watch.
Some become tournament knights or mercenaries
– there’s a whole mercenary group called
the Second Sons who join Daenerys in Game
of Thrones. in the books, Oberyn Martell and
later Tyrion join the Second Sons.
Some second sons are jealous and resentful
of their big brothers – like Stannis with
his brother Robert.
Daemon is a classic example of a second son
who feels overshadowed by his brother.
Corlys is not literally a second son as far
as we know – but House Velaryon has always
been the second family in Westeros, they’re
the Valyrians who don’t have dragons, they’re
always less powerful than the royal Targaryens.
So Corlys and Daemon decide to prove themselves
by going to war with Craghas Crabfeeder.
So in this episode, divisions deepen between
the most powerful people in the realm.
Prince Daemon, Lord Corlys, and Princess Rhaenyra
all feel angry and rejected by the king, setting
the stage for fiery conflicts in the future.
House of the Dragon is based on the book Fire
& Blood – Season 1 covers Chapter 12, Heirs
of the Dragon.
There’s also a shorter summary of the story
in the book The World of Ice and Fire, starting
in the Viserys chapter.
So if you want to know the full story of House
of the Dragon, from beginning to end, with
all the spoilers, you can get either of these
on audiobook for free right now at audible.com/asx.
Sign up for a Premium Plus trial membership,
and you get an audiobook to keep, even if
you cancel the trial.
You can get any Game of Thrones book, or Lord
of the Rings, or Dune.
Membership also includes unlimited access
to thousands of audiobooks and shows in the
Audible Plus Catalog.
Sign up at audible.com/asx, or text asx to
500-500.
Thanks for watching.
We’re doing a House of the Dragon livestream
every Sunday at about 10:15pm Eastern time,
and doing an Explained video like this one
each week.
So like and subscribe, press the bell, follow
the Twitter.
And thanks to the supporters on Patreon, including
Marina Julius, Biggi Smalls, The Bog Queen,
Chris, Brody Franks, Babe, Carley Childress,
and CoffeeRZ.
Cheers.